hello everybody welcome back to my
channel my name is mayuko okay today
we're doing a favorites video because i
haven't done one in a really really
really really really long time since
like the beginnings of my youtube
channel and i was watching it the other
day and i was like look at how much fun
i'm having talking about the things i
love i wanted to do that again because
there's a lot of things in my life right
now that really i so absolutely love
they're like the things that truly have
improved my quality of life bring me joy
by using them and i'm just like so glad
that i like encountered them and then i
met them and that they're a part of my
life right now if you're interested and
like this kind of content then make sure
to subscribe to my channel okay so let's
jump in the first item that i want to
talk about are bug goos
bug goo bag you i don't actually know
what the right pronunciation is these
are reusable bags and i came upon these
i think maybe like a few years ago and
then i recently bought this snoopy set
y'all bagus are like literally the best
reusable bag out there and there are a
few reasons why i really really like
these the first thing that i really like
about them is they come in so many
different colors and patterns and stuff
they're always releasing new ones i
think recently they came out with like a
sanrio pattern but the snoopy one is
part of the take care with peanuts
initiative to help the earth and
sustainability and stuff with snoopy
which i was like
those two are like so my favorite thing
so i bought these the reason why i
really really like these these are far
superior number one
the size this is my hand for reference
these fit in backpacks and bags super
easily uh and i like that it comes in
like a little carrying case like this
when you open it
inside
it's not attached which is fine by me
yeah this bag is like so massive the
bags for bugs like literally fit i feel
like 1.5 times more than all of my other
reusable bags um because there's no
structure to them you can really fill it
quite a lot let me show you i want to
stuff this blanket inside just to show
you
how much
this thing
actually holds look how big it gets
there's some structure but not too much
and so really it takes the shape of
whatever you want if i take this out for
grocery shopping or farmers market or
literally any kind of shopping
like these are it they just hold so so
much no fear of ripping no fear of
tearing and they're cute this is the
earth one with snoopy this is another
snoopy one and then this one has
the peanuts gallery
like this
so what i do with the the pouch
uh that it comes in i just throw it
inside and it doesn't get lost in here
and then when i'm done the best part is
these fold up really neatly even if it
kind of loses the creases and stuff all
you really do is fold it in half
and then fold it
again in half
and then just kind of make a square
and
roll it up so so helpful so freaking
useful i carry at least one or two of
these with me everywhere i love using
them it makes me happy that i'm not
using a bunch of plastic or paper bags
might as well add some joy into your
life with some cute recyclable bags or
reusable bags okay the next item that i
want to talk about is another daily tool
of mine these are the slippers so i
bought these on amazon i think these are
like technically called pillow slippers
or pillow slides or something like that
these are like knockoffs on amazon i
bought these originally because our
first floor used to be all tile and if i
stood for a very long period of time
from cooking or cleaning or something
like that my knees and my back would
start hurting and i was like this is bad
i should take care of my feet a little
bit more i've had these for over a year
you can see the wear on the back and
stuff like that but these have greatly
improved my life there's just so much
cushioning and when you stand on it it
you don't fall through these have held
up really really well they're easy to
clean i just use some soapy water and a
brush and scrub it and they get clean
really really easily these come in a
bunch of different colors and then
there's also so many different versions
of these on amazon i've tried some of
them they're not as soft i think so i'll
link these specific ones in the
description box down below along with
everything else that i've got
[Music]
time for the sponsor segment of today's
video where i want to thank the sponsor
nordvpn so you know what i also really
like one of my favorites that really
does improve my quality of life safely
browsing the internet which especially
if you're in a place like a public space
or something like that which all of us
are trying to do more going to cafes and
going to co-working spaces working from
the airport and stuff like that then you
need a vpn and specifically you need
nordvpn it's super duper easy to use you
can just connect with one click or even
connect with zero clicks with auto
connect they have over 5500 servers in
60 countries so they've got you covered
so maybe there's a tv show or a movie
that you want to watch in a streaming
platform like netflix but it's not
available in your country then you can
simply change your virtual location with
nordvpn and get access it's also been
confirmed that nordvpn is the fastest
vpn out there and it's available
basically on every single platform ios
android windows mac and even linux they
have threat protection that blocks
intrusive ads and web trackers and they
also use disk list servers that store no
data or configurations on site and so
make sure to get the exclusive nordvpn
deal it's risk-free with nord's 30-day
money-back guarantee thank you so much
to nordvpn for sponsoring and now let's
get back to the video
[Music]
so the next items i want to talk about
are kind of like for my own
well-being i guess they're they're
literally just there to make me feel
good and better and stuff like that they
are
asop products so i have this aesop
resurrection aromatique hand bomb
that i bought a while ago i think i also
bought this like six months ago or so
and then this is actually just a sample
of a perfume that they have this one's
called the rozu my parents and scott
think that it smells like a buddhist
temple a little bit it's like a very
nice like when you walk into like a nice
temple that's been really well taken
care of and you smell the wood and the
incense kind of mixed together
and like a little bit of like a floor
release scent and then this one is kind
of like
i have it on my hand right now it's like
kind of citrusy but not outwardly
orangey or lemony i use these when i
need a little pick-me-up especially when
i'm just feeling kind of uh about work
smells and scents just like instantly i
feel like lift your mood so i just put
these on and it lifted my spirits
immediately smells are really great so i
really like these ones the next item
that i have is just a little thing also
that helps me at my desk uh this is cute
little ikea clock so i bought this
because when i'm in like a zoom meeting
or something like that and i need to
look at the time the clock on the mac is
like always in the top right corner and
i feel like it's really obvious when i
look up there
and i didn't want it to be that obvious
because i felt like it was kind of rude
to just be like hey i'm talking to you
i'm talking and talking i'm checking the
time talking and talking and talking i'm
taking the time to make sure that we
haven't gone over and whatever and so i
wanted something that wasn't in the top
right something that wasn't so obvious
where i can still check the time to make
sure that get to my next meetings on
time i wanted something to put on my
desk i looked at a bunch of different
clocks and i just came upon this one
from ikea i think it's a new one it just
uses one triple a double a oh my god
it's so hard to open
it uses a battery i can't open it it's
like too hard to open it also has a
little alarm function and you can set
the time using these buttons back here i
just really like it because it's cute it
looks like a little easel and the design
is very playful and the color is really
cute and i like that it's digital too so
i can actually see it's synced exactly
with my phone so it changes time exactly
when the time changes and now when i'm
in a meeting i can just glance down
which i feel like is a more natural
thing to do with your eyes when you're
like in a meeting instead of looking at
the top right because what i don't know
it just feels weird to me so i bought
this really like it it's just gonna stay
on my desk forever my next favorite
thing is a very recent addition actually
to
my life and that's this yeti water
bottle this is a 26 ounce water bottle
and let me tell you why i like this one
so yes this one is expensive i'm not
gonna lie i paid forty dollars for this
but i've used multiple hydro flasks i've
used contigos and i think honestly that
the yeti water bottle is the best design
the thing that the yeti can do that
others can't number one
it has a little like drinking spout
thing which i really like having because
when the spout's too big
obviously you're gonna get water all
over yourself when you drink it and so i
like having like a little straw top or
like a small top to drink from it's a
lot easier to drink from and
specifically i like this one because
it's not actually a straw it's just a
really simple top and this is really
important because it's freaking hard to
clean a straw but this is just such a
simple design that you can clean it with
a sponge this number one i was just like
why don't all water bottles have
something like this and then this this
screw top just goes on top here you can
hold it number two is that the lip here
is super duper big and that's important
because
when you are cleaning a water bottle yes
you could use a water bottle brush but
that's like an additional thing that you
need to buy in order to clean your water
bottles and i just feel like even with a
brush you're not going to get to every
single part of the inside of a water
bottle so it still feels kind of
unhygienic to me i really like this one
because i can actually reach my whole
hand inside
to the very bottom and so i can actually
clean every corner an inch of this water
bottle without needing a brush and it's
like the keeper drinks cool and hot
insulated doesn't sweat it's not plastic
and so if you leave it in your car your
water is not going to taste like plastic
it's unfortunate that it's so expensive
because it's just such a good water
bottle but at this point
at almost 30 i've been through so many
water bottles and i know that i feel
better if i hydrate well and i know that
i'll hydrate well if i have a water
bottle that i like using and cleaning so
there you have it i spent that money on
a yeti water bottle and i'm not turning
back the next thing that i want to talk
about is something that i don't have in
my hand right now because i'm using it
right now it's a new camera i bought a
new camera so i bought the fujifilm xt4
which i am filming on right now this is
my very first filming session with it
and i quite like it so i'm still very
new to this camera i'm still learning
how to use it and all but just from a
design standpoint i'm coming from the
canon eos r and so the thing that i
really like about this fujifilm xt4 so
far it's just so cute looking i bought
the silver version so it honestly looks
like a film camera and so i really like
the design of it i also like that the
knobs on top are manual for aperture and
shutter speed and exposure those things
have really always been really hard to
get to from like digital menus and stuff
on sony's and canons and i'm just like
why it has a flip out screens that i
need to do video i can plug in a
microphone the lens that i got is the
18-55 which is a pretty good zoom lens
but i love that it's not super massive
it actually kind of just looks like a
prime lens my plan is to take this
camera out on adventures and take
pictures and photos and i really wanted
something that was compact but versatile
as a lens and i found it in this one so
yeah still just kind of first
impressions here because i haven't used
it very much but so far i really really
like it never considered getting a fuji
film for my camera but there's this
youtube channel that i started following
and they use the fujifilm and i was like
yeah let's just try it out and i am
pleasantly surprised if you want a more
like in-depth video about like the
cameras that i use and what i like about
all my different cameras then leave a
comment down below and be happy to talk
about all the tools that i use for
filming the last thing i want to talk
about that is like improves my quality
of life makes me super happy one of my
all-time faves is music related and i
really want to talk about this band
because i freaking love all of their
music they are lawrence they are a
brother-sister combo with also a bunch
of friends from college i think it's an
eight-person band with an entire brass
section that makes a lot of really good
kind of soul pop funk r b ish but like
just really fun music i'll definitely
link like a youtube video to one of my
favorite songs in the description box
down below so you can listen to it but
their music is just so genuinely energy
giving i really like don't lose sight
and so damn fast and probably up and
casualty i actually had the pleasure of
going to see them right before covet it
was like early march in san francisco
and literally everybody was like buffing
their head dancing like it was just so
like good good energy so i really hope
you give them a listen because they're
like just literally one of my favorite
bands i feel like they're still
kind of like coming up to being more
popular their don't lose sight
like song got really really popular
recently but they're just so good and i
really really like them all right so
those are all of my items my favorite
things that improve my quality of life
make me happy whatever like just all of
those things i really love all of these
things truly i like literally think you
can't go wrong with these things if you
have similar tastes in things as me then
you're probably going to enjoy them too
again all of the links to these things
are going to be in the description box
so i hope you check them out
if you like these kinds of favorites
videos let me know in the comments down
below um if you like any of the things
that i use and you also think they're
awesome let me know as well uh and i
think that's it for today we've got a
lot of cool videos coming up in the next
few weeks so make sure to subscribe
again um and follow me on instagram all
that good kind of stuff social media
influencer thingies so hope y'all are
doing well and i'll see you next time
bye
[Music]